aha I thought my jokes were bad give me
one reason why I shouldn't have my boy
to pull your head off how about a magic
track I'm gonna make this pencil
disappear oh and by the way the suit it
wasn't cheap you oughta know you bought
it sit I want to hear proposition
let's wind the clocks back a year these
cops and lawyers wouldn't dare cross any
of you I mean what happens you do balls
drop off hmm you see a guy like me Frank
a guy like me look listen I know why you
choose to have your little mmm
group therapy sessions in broad daylight
I know why you're afraid to go out at
night the Batman is he Batman has shown
Gotham your true colors unfortunately
dent
he's just the beginning and as for the
televisions so-called plan Batman has no
jurisdiction he'll find him and make him
squeal I know the squealers when I see
them and who do you propose it's simple
we kill the battery if it's so simple
why haven't you done it already if
you're good at something never do it for
free
Oh what you will
no I'm not if we don't deal with this
now
soon little gamble here won't be able to
get it a nickel for his grandma enough
from the clown let's not blow this out
of proportion you think you could steal
from us and just walk away yeah I'm
putting the word out 500 grand for this
clown did a million alive so I can teach
him some manners first all right so
listen why didn't you give me a call
when you want to start taking things a
little more seriously here's my card
you